bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver sur Figaro
live et Figaro radio nous allons suivre
ensemble l'hommage national présidé par
Emmanuel Macron dans le cadre des
attentats entre enfin du Hamas en Israël
au total 42 français ont perdu la vie
c'est le plus lourd bilan depuis
l'attentat de Nice le 14 juillet 2016 TR
sont toujours portés disparu nous allons
revenir évidemment sur les enjeux de cet
hommage national qui sera présidé dans
quelques instants par Emmanuel Macron et
nous allons faire également un point sur
ce qu'il se passe actuellement au Proche
Orient bonjour Isabelle lasser bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
rédactrice en chef adjointe au service
international du Figaro 4 mois jour pour
jour voilà 4 mois nous sépare de cette
terrible attaque du Hamas en Israël
certaines familles estiment que ça
arrive bien tard est-ce qu'elles ont
raison et pourquoi a-t-il lieu si tard
cet hommage national alors est-ce
qu'elles ont raison oui et non hein pour
les victimes de famille ce ce genre
d'hommage arrive toujours forcément
beaucoup trop tard je crois qu'une
grande partie des Français pendant assez
longtemps n'ont pas réussi à en fait à à
s'investir sur le caractère français de
ces victimes et il les considérait avant
tout comme des victimes israéliennes
pour le côté politique c'est vrai qu'on
était vraiment dans le le cœur de la
guerre que la question de la libération
des otages a un petit peu ralenti tous
les autres processus et finalement on
peut se dire alors c'est tard pour les
familles mais en même temps la France
c'est le premier pays à organisé un
hommage national pour les victimes des
attentats terroristes du Hamas le 7
octobre donc c'est quand même aussi le
premier pays alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
énormément de critiques qui entourent
cette cérémonie d'hommage nationale qui
qui se tiendra dans quelques instants
aux Invalides ce sera à suivre sur le
Figaro.fr à partir de d' 11h45 et en
l'occurrence la principale critique
c'est la présence des responsables de la
France insoumise est-ce que ces
critiques sont justifiées est-ce que la
France insoumise a sa place parmi les
spectateurs de de cet hommage alors pour
moi elle n'a pas elle n'a pas sa place
après ce après ce qui s'est passé après
les mots commis par la France insoumise
après toutes ces phrases d'ambigué et
surtout depuis le début la France a
soumise a absolument refusé de en fait
reconnaître le caractère terroriste des
attaques du Hamas du 7 octobre et c'est
vrai que tous les leaders de la France
insoumis depuis le début essayent de
dresser des équivalences
entre les attaques d'un mouvement
terroriste et la réponse de légitime
défense d'une armée régulière d'une
démocratie qui certes est violente mais
n'est pas du tout sur le même sur le
même point
les responsables de la France insoumis
ont fait preuve de révisionnisme et de
négationnisme alors une fois qu'on a dit
ça c'est une cérémonie républicaine et
il est logique que le chef de l'État est
invité tous les parlementaire à s'y
rendre et s'il ne l'avait pas fait on
lui aurait reproché d'avoir exclu une
partie des élus de la République
française donc ça devrait être à chaque
parlementaire de juger si sa place est
aujourd'hui aux invalides ou non je
pense que les leaders de la France
insoumises essayent ainsi par le
présence par leur présence de de se
blanchir en fait ou pour faire un
honorable quelque part ouais absolument
d'acheter d'acheter une nouvelle
légitimité je je crains fort que ça ne
suffira pas alors on va parler de ce qui
se passe un petit peu en ce moment au
Proche Orient parce que l'actualité se
déroule toujours là-bas c'est vrai que
parfois on a tendance peut-être à en
parler un petit peu peu moins mais les
frappes israéliennes continuent il y a
une véritable tension là-bas au Proche
Orient et l'objectif bien évidemment de
de de d'Israël c'est toujours de
détruire le Hamas est-ce que selon vous
Isabelle lasser il est possible de
détruire le Hamas tout en libérant les
otages puisqu'il est question de ça on
va en parler évidemment beaucoup au
cours de cette cérémonie domhommage aux
Invalides est-ce qu'il est possible de
faire les deux de réussir les deux
objectifs détruire d'un côté ce groupe
terroriste et puis parvenir à
sauvegarder la vie de ceux qui sont
encore détenus là-bas à Gaza alors alors
déjà je pense que la première partie de
l'objectif est en elle-même difficile
même si on fait abstraction des otages
puisque détruire le hamass oui on peut
détruire ça prend du ça prendra du temps
parce qu'on s'est aperçu ENF le le le
les infrastructures du Hamas
représentent une une ville entière une
ville souterraine on avait complètement
les Israéliens avaient complètement
sous-estimé en fait la la la complexité
et la et la et la force la puissance en
fait de cette deuxème ville qui é
installée sous Gaza donc
détruire les infrastruc structure
militaire du Hamas et les principaux
commandants est responsable oui c'est
possible ça prendra du temps détruire
l'idéologie du Hamas ça va être beaucoup
compqu déjà ça ce n'est pas possible et
alors détruire le Hamas tout en libérant
les otages c'est la c'est la le choix
cornélien enfin la question insoluble à
laquelle est confrontée l'armée
israélienne tal depuis le début parce
que les les les otages sont le principal
levier du Hamas et en fait elle ralentit
la détention des otages ralentit les
opérations de tsal empêche en fait tsal
de de d'y aller plus fort en fait dans
les tunnels et c'est très compliqué
c'està-dire Queen fait il faudrait que
d'un dans une première étape les otages
soient libérés à l'issue de négociations
diplomatiques et qu'ensuite
Israël continue son son son en fait sa
réponse militaire pour punir le Hamas le
problème c'est que le ass c'est à quel
point les otages ont une valeur
absolument inestimable et en fait les
protègeent c'est comme un espèce de
bouclier humain géant les otages pour le
Hamas est-ce que l'armée israélienne est
parvenu à couper la tête du serpent
est-ce qu'ils sont parvenus vraiment à à
mettre un coup d'arrêt à ce groupe
terroriste qui est le Hamas aujourd'hui
on sait que les frappes continuent
est-ce que le Hamas est en mesure encore
de répliquer pourquoi pas d'envahir
encore Israël ou bien ce groupe
terroriste est en train est en être
repli et en train vraiment de bah de
mourir enfin il a été euh il a été
vraiment diminué mais on voit qu'il
n'est pas euh qu' n'est pas mort
d'ailleurs depuis quelques temps il y a
il y a eu à nouveau en fait des des
nouvelles attaques du Hamas au nord de
la bande de Gaza alors qu'on pensait que
ce Nord avait été en fait nettoyé et
qu'on avait chassé tous les combattant
du Hamas de cette partie par ailleurs le
Hamas très affaibli à Gaza enfin de plus
en plus à à en fait euh est en train de
de d'obtenir une légitimité nouvelle en
tout cas politique en cjordanie donc on
n pas encore éradiqué la puissance de
nuisance du Hamas et une fois qu'on a
dit ça il y a un autre groupe terroriste
qui pose problème c'est le c'est le
hzbollah qui a une capacité
euh de de de d'attaque euh contre Israël
10 fois supérieure à celle du Hamas
c'est-à-dire que le hbollah est un
groupe beaucoup plus armé alors pour
l'instant euh le le hzbollah qui dépend
en fait de de de l'Iran pour l'instant
il est évident que l'Iran ne veut pas
rentrer en guerre directement contre
Israël et contre les États-Unis mais à
terme pour Israël la question du Hamas
sera en quelqu de la question du
Hezbollah sera en quelque sorte la même
que celle du Hamas c'est-à-dire israël
va va va-t-elle pouvoir vivre ouis euh
longtemps avec des mouvements terrorist
qui veulent sa destruction donc le
travail pour répondre à votre question
on n'est pas au bout de on n'est pas au
bout du processus est-ce que l'état
d'esprit des Israéliens a
considérablement changé depuis cette
attaque du 7 octobre on sait que ce
peuple vivait plus ou moins en sécurité
en tout cas avait ce sentiment de
sécurité est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vraiment
il y a eu un avant et un après de ce
point de vue-l ça je pense que c'est
clair et je pense que en fait la la la
puissance de choc en fait représenté par
les attentats terroristes du 7 octobre a
été complètement sous-estimé en Europe
c'est-à-dire à la fois en fait Israël du
jour au lendemain s'est retrouvé être un
pays fragile qui ne peut plus qui n'a
pas pu tenir sa promesse de faire vivre
les Israéliens en sécurité de de
maintenir son ce refuge qui avait été
créé après la Choa en 1945 mais aussi
les Israéliens ont réalisé à quel point
ça ça donc c'est c'est l'attaque
terroriste contre la sécurité d'Israël
mais il y a aussi la violence
psychologique puisque les les attentats
terroristes ont été des attentats d'une
barbarie euh que même daesh n'avait pas
n'avait pas commis c'est-à-dire que des
femmes enceintes ont été éventrées des
des des enfants ont été décapités des
femmes ont été violé par plusieurs
hommes à la fois on leur a coupé les
seins enfin c'est absolument
épouvantable ce qui s'est produit et
donc euh on a vu cette cette barbarie
euh dirigé contre vraiment contre contre
les Juifs donc le choc psychologique ne
peut pas en fait disparaître comme ça en
5 minutes il y a un avant et un après et
je pense qu'Israël après le 7 octobre ne
sera plus du tout le même Israël et les
Israéliens vont mettre sans doute des
années en fait à à à digérer ça et et je
pense que cette attaque va induire trans
à la fois dans la société dans la
politique et dans la manière dont Israël
se situe dans tout le Moyen-Orient alors
le premier ministre du Qatar a affirmé
mardi avoir reçu une réponse positive du
Hamas sur un projet d'accord qui prévoit
la libération d'otage détenu dans la
bande de Gaza alors la contrepartie est
la suivante une pause dans les combats
entre Israël et le groupe terroriste
est-ce que ça c'est une source d'espoir
crédible non c'est une source d'espoir
mais en fait c'est c'est on voit les bon
les tentatives de la diplomatique ne
s'arrêtent pas et c'est c'est c'est très
bien le Qatar est vraiment au centre de
ces tentatives diplomatique après il
faut qu'elle corresponde à tout le monde
il n'est pas certain aujourd'hui que le
le package qui soit proposé à Israël
soit acceptable par le gouvernement de
netaniaahou donc on en est vraiment au
prémis mais c'est vrai que il y a une en
fait un certain nombre de pays en fait
c'est le Qatar ce sont les les pays du
Golf il les États-Unis l'Europe que tout
le monde en fait converge ses efforts
diplomatiques pour obtenir une trêve et
la libération des otages et accélérer en
fait l'avèement d'un processus
diplomatique qui pourtant aujourd'hui
paraît encore assez loin alors on va
voir dans quelques instants les images
des Invalides sur Le Figaro.fr puisque
je vous le rappelle on va suivre dans
quelques instants la cérémonie d'hommage
national présidée par Emmanuel Macron et
bien vous voyez au moment où je parle
vous les voyez vous voyez notamment
Gérard Larcher de dos qui est arrivé
dans la cour des Invalides avec la
tribune présidentielle Emmanuel Macron
devrait prononcer normalement un
discours à partir de midi il devrait
arriver dans les toutes prochaines
minutes c'est vrai que les États-Unis
Isabelle lasser on s'en est rendu compte
notamment au cours des dernières
tractations joue un rôle diplomatique
très important dans cette guerre entre
Israël et le Hamas quel est le rôle de
la France aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils ont
est-ce que la notre pays a des leviers
diplomatiques pour pouvoir avoir une
véritable influence dans ce conflit euh
les leviers de la France sont
considérablement euh réduits par rapport
à ce qu'ils pouvait être il y a une
dizaine d'années euh ce n'est pas
forcément lié à la politique actuelle du
gouvernement même s'il y a eu des des
des faux pas qui ont été qui se sont
produits au début de la guerre
c'est-à-dire que Emmanuel Macron n'est
sans doute pas assz venu assez
rapidement rendre un hommage aux
victimes en Israël c'est-à-dire qu'il
aurait sans doute dû foncer euh auprès
du gouvernement israélien le le le 8
octobre il a il a attendu assez
longtemps pour le faire il a ensuite
proposé des choses qui étaient un non
sens comme une coalition internationale
mais euh c'est c'est c'est la perte
d'influence de la France est liée à
d'autres choses c'est-à-dire que
euh en fait il faut replacer ça dans la
la perte d'influence globale de l'Europe
et de et de et de l'Occident et de la
montée Sud Glob en fait du Sud global et
des pays émergents dans la région et euh
aujourd'hui c'est plus la France qui
compte
aucun pays européen n'est en fait
suffisamment fort aujourd'hui pour avoir
une influence décisive que ce soit dans
la guerre au Proche Orient ou que ce
soit dans la guerre en Ukraine donc
l'Europe pourra avoir une capacité
d'influence mais elle est pour l'instant
relativement divisé ceux qui ont une
véritable influence aujourd'hui alors
c'est encore les États-Unis mais on on
voit bien que cette influence se réduit
elle aussi comme pot de chagrin parce
que les États-Unis se
sont retiré enfin en tout cas ont
manifesté leur volonté de se retirer au
Moyen-Orient parce que Barack Obama a
failli en Syrie parce qu'il n'a pas en
fait en 2013 il avait brûlé sa sa
promesse et laissé filer sa ligne rouge
qui était de de d'intervenir en fait
après un un attentat chimique donc dans
la région les États-Unis sont considérés
comme en fait un pays qui ne tient plus
forcément ses promesses et en même temps
il y a la montée d'acteur
euh qui s'affirme tous les jours de plus
en plus alors c'est le Qatar ça c'est de
manière plus ponctuelle mais il y a un
un immense pays qui à mon avis est est
est voué à à jouer un rôle absolument
majeur dans la résolution de ce conflit
c'est l'Arabie c'est l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est l'Arabie Saoudite alors
aujourd'hui les c'est l'influence est
plutôt dans les coulisses les les
Saoudiens ne veulent pas en fait se se
mettre tout le tout le les U dans le
même panier ils veulent rester assez
discret parce que ce qui leur importe en
fait c'est de maintenir la stabilité
dans la région et de ne pas perturber
leurs projet économique et leur projet
pour 20030 les saudiens n'ont aucun
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait une contagion
les saouiens n'ont aucun intérêt à ce
qu'il y ait une contagion mais c'est le
plus pays le plus le le plus le plus
stable et le plus fort de la région il
est évident
qu'ils ont un rôle à jouer qu'ils auront
un rôle à jouer alors Stéphan séjourné
le ministre des Affaires étrangères a
entamé cette semaine une tournée au
Proche Orient quel est l'objet de cette
visite au juste bah l'objet de cette
visite il est de de de en fait de de de
de replacer la France enfin d'essayer de
la replacer au cœur du jeu politique et
de faire en sorte que la France et
l'Europe quand sera venu le temps des
négociations parce qu'il il viendra
forcément un jour soit autour de la
table et c'est vrai que la France a un
rôle particulier puisqu'elle a une
politique qu'elle dit être une politique
d'équilibre et qui consiste depuis
surtout depuis le l'avènement d'Emmanuel
Macron hein qui fait toujours du du en
même temps le cœur de sa politique qui
consiste à parler à toutes les parties
et avoir des bons rapports à toutes les
par avec toutes les parties la France en
outre a une tradition de politique arabe
notamment à l'époque depuis l'époque de
Jacques Chirac
qui est très ancrée dans la diplomatie
française et donc elle a une voix qui a
longtemps porté donc c'est ce qu'essaie
de faire Stéphane ses journé il a raison
ça ne suffira pas à débloquer le dossier
mais la France est un des CIN pays
membres du Conseil de sécurité aux
Nations Unies elle a toujours eu avant
une influence assez forte dans la région
il se il ne serait pas normal qu'elle ne
qu'elle n'essaie pas de de de de de
prendre sa part et d'essayer de de de
faire en sorte que les choses ne ne
dégénèrent pas la France a aussi une
relation absolument particulière avec le
Liban et le Liban est au cœur de ce
conflit puisque le Liban est le nid en
fait du du esbollah du esbollah
absolument vous venez de voir sur les
images diffusées sur Le Figaro.fr
Emmanuel Macron vient de faire son
arrivée dans la cour des Invalides il a
salué les autorités militaires il est
accompagné de son épouse on a pu voir le
chef de l'État avec la mine grave bien
évidemment on va suivre évidemment ce
cet hommage national aux victimes
français du Hamas dans dans quelques
instants sur le Figaro.fr je voulais
aussi parler de l'organisation des des
Nations Unies avec vous Isabelle lasser
parce que vous l'avez notamment très
bien expliqué dans un papier qu'on peut
relire encore sur le Figaro.fr qu'une
dizaine d'employés de l'Agence des
nations- Unies pour les réfugiés
palestinien était accusé d'avoir
participé aux attentats terroristes du 7
octobre alors là sincèrement quand j'ai
lu ça je suis tombé de ma chaise alors
peut-être naïvement mais en attendant on
peut quand même se poser la question
est-ce que l'ONU est encore crédible
aujourd'hui sur la scène internationale
alors il y a plusieurs en fait il y a
plusieurs ONU il y a plusieurs questions
il est clair que l'unra donc est
complètement a été complètement noyauté
en fait par le Hamas ça c'est une
première chose euh ceci appelle une
autre question est-ce que on
doit aujourd'hui couper les les vivres
de cette organisation des Nations Unies
en pleine guerre de Gaza alors que en
fait c'est souvent la seule source
de de en fait de de humanitaire pour les
Palestiniens je crois qu'il faut d'un
côté que la justice fasse son travail et
que les leçons soient tirées de des
compromissions et des ambiguïtés de
cette agence de l'ONU et en même temps
déconnecter le le le en fait le le les
besoins humanitaires des Palestiniens
euh après l'ONU si vous parlez de l'ONU
de de la grande ONU de or qu'elle n'est
pas elle noyautée par le Hamas c'est
c'est un autre problème c'est qu'elle
est en fait bloquée elle est bloquée par
les véau de deux grands pays la Chine et
la Russie qui essayent en fait qui ont
un un un un agenda en fait un qui ont un
obj qui ont l'objectif de changer
l'ordre international et de remplacer le
système international actuel par un
nouvel ordre qui leur serait plus plus
favorable c'estàdire que la Chine et la
Russie considèrent que d'ailleurs pas
forcément à tort que l'ordre depuis 1945
a été dominé par les États-Unis par
l'Europe et que les rapports dans le de
force dans le monde aujourd'hui ont
changé ils ne veulent plus de ces
institutions internationales qui de leur
point de vue ne les servent pas assez
ils essayent de en fait donner des coups
de marteau pour ébranler de plus en plus
fort les murs de ces institutions
internationales alors aujourd'hui elles
sont complètement paral
et on se demande
effectivement quel sera leur avenir et
si elles vont en fait
survivre aujourd'hui en fait l'ancien
monde est est détruit le nouveau monde
n'est pas encore construit nous sommes
dans cette phase de transition où le
précédent monde est encore en train de
se détruire on ne sait pas encore de
quoi sera fait le prochain monde et bien
merci beaucoup Isabelle lasser pour
votre décryptage rappelle que vous êtes
rédactrice en chef adjointe au service
intern international du Figaro merci
d'avoir été sur ce plateau pour nous
donner les clés avant cet hommage
national aux victimes du 7 octobre que
l'on va suivre en direct sur Le
Figaro.fr Emmanuel Macron est arrivé
dans la cour des Invalides la garde
nationale vous l'avez vu la garde
républicaine a commencé effectivement à
jouer de la musique on va suivre ça tout
de suite sur Le Figaro.fr on se retrouve
juste après pour décrypter ce qui vient
de se passer et revenir sur les moments
clés de cet hommage
[Musique]
la cour des Invalides est trop
étroite Mo jour pour
jour
après car nous sommes 68 millions de
Français
endeillés par les attaques terroristes
du 7 octobre
dernier 68
millions moin 40 de vies
fauché 68
millions dont si vies
blessé
millions dont qu viill à jamais meurtri
par leur
captivité 68
millions dont TR vies sont encore
prisonnières pour la libération
desquelles nous luttons chaque jour
leurs chais VI sont
là
or
les visages des suppliciés du 7 octobre
nous tendent un miroir où se reflète un
peu de nous dans chacun
d'ux de ce que nous étions de ce que
nous serons à leurs
âges de ce qu'ils ne seront
jamais il n'avait pas 20
ans commean ont
jamais leur trait qui s'affirme leur
question qui se bousculle Dieu la vie le
monde les hésitations et l'irrévérence
leur regards comme des interrogations
leur sourire en forme de
promesse mémoire de nos propres
adolescences il n'avait pas 30
ans
Avidan Valentin Naomi ne les auront
jamais des rêves plein la tête des
études de droit ou
d'informatique un métier un grand
amour des
fiançailles la foi ou l'athéisme une
guitare une planche de surf sur les
vagues de la méditérrané des idé dans la
houle du
monde ils étaient dans la force de l'âge
sine Marc
Ellias ne vieilliront
pas leur chemin frayé a pris d'efforts
peuplé de projets d'amis d'enfants
parfois et ce sourire qui n'aura pas eu
le temps de marquer leur
visage ils avaient les tempes
grises pour Carmela jean-paulfard
elle ne blanch
plus leur voix raisonnent encore en
hébreu comme en français leur voix qui
se cassait par moment de tendresse ou de
pudeur transmettant des récits puisés au
fond des âges que leur avait livré leurs
propres
grands-parents leurs visages sont
là comme autant de vie
interrompu des histoires de famillees où
sentrebaillit parfois un grouffre ible
et où comme l'odeur de l'espérance le
parfum des collines de Jérusalem se
mêlait à celui de ce bois d'île-de-fance
ou des ruelles du vieux
port le 7 octobre dernier
àom l'indisble a ressurgi des
profondeurs de
l'histoire il était
6h au festival Nova à quelques
kilomètres de la bande de
Gaza où sous les banderoles et le ciel
qui palissait s'achevait 24 heur de fête
et de
retrouvailles les jeunes qui dansaient
là ne savaient pas qu'ils étaient dans
la mâchoire de la mort
déjà des voitures des motos hérisses
d'armes allit fondre sur
eux il était
6h et le Hamas lança par
surprise l'attaque massive et
odieuse le plus grand massacre
antisémite de notre
siècle et dans les notes de musique d'un
lieu de F ont éclaté les tambours de
l'enfer et les téléphones de nos enfants
qui jusque là film les joies de leur vie
sont devenu les boîtes noires de
l'horreur
nous ces images le ciel livide qui se
zèbre de
missile les brigades infernales qui
écument le festival se répandent dans
les plaines puis dans les villages
fracassent les portes font irruption
dans les foyers dans les chambres sous
les lits les déflagrations les cris de
massacr les Juifs les grenades les
hurlements les pleurs puis le
silence comme un
seul
le
silence face à
l'indiscible la
sidération face à la
sauvagerie les
larme face à la
barbarie la
barbarie celle qui brûle et qui brise
qui abuse et qui
tue celle qui déch les familles abatt
une petite fille parce qu'elle ralentit
la colonne he sur son chemin un enfant
en pyjama en tue un autre au cremême des
bras de son père celle qui ni la joie
l'art la culture la liberté de la fête
et nos cœurs se serrent aux échos du
Bataclan de Nice ou de
Strasbourg la
barbarie celle qui fauche cette jeunesse
à peine éclos
qui ravage et qui bout souvent fort de
conviction pacifiste prêt à entendre la
souffrance palestinienne que les
terroristes ont piétiner en prétendant
la
défendre la
barbarie celle qui se nourrit
d'antisémitisme et qui le
propage celle qui veut les
détruire et qui pourtant ne peut
empêcher des rayons de lumière au milieu
de la
nuit les messages
d'adieu de ces jeunes qui savent qu'ils
vont mourir et qui envoient à leurs
parents une dernière expression d'amour
et de
gratitude cet homme qui s'interpose
entre l'explosion d'une grenade et ses
deux enfants sauvant leur vie au prix de
la
sienne et le sacrifice de cet autre père
qui n'était pas sur les lieux de
l'attaque et qui quand il a reçu l'appel
de sa fille pris sous le feu des tirs à
Nova a sauté dans sa voiture pour aller
la chercher allant au devant de la
mort la
barbarie et nos
lumières car ceux qui tuent par
haine trouveront toujours face à
eux ceux qui sont prêts à mourir par
amour et toujours ils verront s'élever
contre notre pays qui ce 7 octobre a été
touché dans sa
chair de Montpellier à
télaviv de Bordeaux au néev les morts
français du 7 octobre n'étaiit pas tous
nés sur le sol de
France ils ne sont pas tombés sous le
ciel de
France mais ils étaient de
France de France parce qu'ils la portait
en eux et que notre pays était partout
où ils
étaient de France parce qu'ils avaient
l'exigence de l'idéal le goût de
l'universel de France parce qu'ils
aimaient notre pays avec la force
ardente de ceux qui en apprenant sa
langue se plongeant dans sa culture ne
le quitte
jamais et en cette
Cour sur notre sol que certains
n'avaient jamais
foulé leurs visages sont
là rappelant les de leur
vie la trace ineffaçable qu'il laisse
dans les nôtres notre viatique pour
l'éternité leurs destins ne sont pas les
seuls que le déchirement du MoyenOrient
continue de broyer dans cette tornade de
souffrance qu'est la
guerre et toutes les vies se valent
inestimables aux yeux de la
France et et les vies que nous honorons
aujourd'hui sont
tombées victime d'un terrorisme que nous
combattons sous toutes ses formes et qui
nous a frappé en plein
cœur la France recueillant ses enfants
parmi d'autres de ses enfants dont elle
n'oublie
aucun refusant les séparations comme les
divisions refusant l'esprit de mort de
chaos et de clivage que nourrissent
précisément les terroristes
jamais en nous nous ne laisserons
prospérer l'esprit de
revanche et dans ces moments de deuil
dans les épreuves du temps rien jamais
ne doit nous
diviser la France restera unie pour
elle-même et pour les autres unie pour
se tenir audelà des destins et des
différences au sein de notre nation un
dans ces moment de souffrance pour les
Israéliens et les Palestiniens afin de
vraer sans relâche pour répondre aux
aspirations à la paix et à la sécurité
de tous au Proche
Orient
bettharim dit-on en
Israël pour désigner les
cimetières la maison de la
vie car pour ceux qui
restent leur vie sera
faite de ces
absences une vie différente un monde
différent à l'ône du
souvenir et nous avons dès lors à
habiter ce
deuil non pas comme une victoire de la
mort mais comme une invitation àors
trouver une place dans nos VI
vie et ils sont là chacune et
chacun pour nous rappeler que nos vies
leur vie mérite sans relâche de nous
battre contre les idées de haine de ne
rien céder à un antisémitisme rampant
désinhibé ici comme là-bas car rien ne
le justifie rien car rien ne serait
justifié ni excuser ce terrorisme
rien alors nous nous tenons
là 4 mois
après devant ses visages et ses chais
vide bouleversé de
tristesse au côté des familles de ceux
qui ne sont
plus chargé
d'affection au côté de ceux qui soignent
leurs
blessures et ne cédant rien pour ramener
ceux qui sont encore
là-bas sentiment mêlés que nous vivons
ensemble
debout car regardant ces
visages nous savons que nous ne sommes
pas juste 68 millions en ce
jour nous sommes beaucoup
plus un peuple et pris de liberté
de
fraternité de
dignité un
peuple qui ne les oubliera
jamais vive la République vive la
France
[Musique]
la
contre
[Musique]
et
i
jegoie
[Musique]
I